Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday. Greetings from beautiful and somewhat windy, Chamberland, South Dakota. So, Hank, earlier today
I signed what I believed to be every copy of Turtles All The Way Down
currently available for sale or borrowing in Sioux Falls, South Dakota,
and I met a lot of wonderful librarians, and booksellers, and confused Target shoppers.
And I also filmed the whole thing, and it would have made a great video,
but then I destroyed my memory card. What happened--and I desperately wish I were making this up--
is that I was eating pretzel chips by the handful, because of course I was, while fiddling with my memory card and--um--
somehow my hands got confused about what was what.
I mean, to be fair, a memory card and a pretzel chip have almost the exact same thickness and overall weight,
but really that's not a great excuse. So yeah, what happened is that I put the memory card into my mouth,
and then I chewed it. The weird part--well actually I guess it's all weird parts--but the weirdest part
is that when I bit down on the memory card, my first thought was, 'huh that pretzel
chip is very crunchy,' and so my natural reaction was to attempt to chew it again. Now,
it does not appear to be damaged--there's a couple very small tooth marks--but, it's toast.
I'm gonna let this frustration go in a minute, but just as a parting remark,
I would like to note that it says right here on the memory card that it is an 'Extreme Pro
Memory Card'. And, look, obviously I shouldn't have chewed on my memory card, but I would argue that any non-food
Item that can be destroyed by human chewing should not describe itself as 'Extreme Pro'. Alright,
let's go on a tour bus bus tour. Hey, that's a palindrome--nope--
no, it is definitely not. So, the first thing you see when you come inside
is the driver's seat--that's where Brock lives. Once you walk onto the bus, you come to the first seating area
which I like to think of as the office. It's sort of the quiet part of the bus where everybody's always on their computer answering
emails, etc.
But the great thing about the office, is that it's also sort of the dining room due to its proximity to the kitchen. By the
way, there are the offending pretzel chips...
We really have everything you need in a kitchen; a microwave, a sink, and a banana holder. Past that, you get to the
bathroom. We have a very nicely appointed, if somewhat small, bathroom; but there's one very important rule about the bus bathroom
which is no pooping in the bus bathroom, not because of like moral concerns,
but the tubes are too small. Then you come to our refrigerator, which is mostly diet soda, La Croix,
there's some beer, there's some baby carrots down there that nobody's ever eaten... And then past the bathroom,
we have the bedrooms: eight beautiful bunks. Here's mine. I'm sorry
I didn't make my bed for you, but here are two cute puppies I got at Target Headquarters. Hank's bunk is directly beneath mine--
--he didn't make his bed either. And then past the bedroom, is the second seating area
which I like to think of as, like, the rec room because it contains my Nintendo switch.
So, this is kind of the hangout area--because the engines right back there,
it's a little bit louder and there's more side-to-side motion; and when we first started on tour,
everyone was really nauseated and nobody wanted to sit back here,
but now we've all got our bus legs. Now, the great thing about the bus is that there's so much storage, like you know, that bag
which contains 850 plastic Turtles. In fact, there's plastic Turtles everywhere. We've got plastic Turtles in the shoe closet,
we've got a cute little turtle moose in the Sharpie drawer--yes, we have a Sharpie drawer,--
--we've even got some Holden turtle fields in the microwave.See, he's wearing his people hunting hat.
We've even got Turtles with top hats in our popcorn and applesauce drawer.
It really is kind of a Turtles all the way down situation. Okay, Hank,
I'm gonna go hide some signed plastic turtles here in Chamberlain, South Dakota.
We're leaving them everywhere we stopped; you can find hints to their location on my Instagram story.
And thanks again to everyone in Sioux Falls who was so incredibly nice to me--
--sorry that I chewed on all of our memories. Hank, I will see you on Friday--actually
I'll see you like on Thursday, but you know what I mean.